hi there Steve Kaufman here again to
talk about language learning and today
I'm going to talk about spaced
repetition systems Enki memorize
supermemo and what I think their role is
in language learning
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe
oh and I should point out that this
morning I phoned into echo Moskvy
because their ma Tigana Polsky and his
sidekicks have a program there were they
speak in Russian and Ukrainian and it
sort of introduces the Ukrainian
language to Russians so I phoned in and
spoke very briefly with them in
Ukrainian if I can figure out how to
extract the recording I will put it up
might be today might be in my next video
ah no space repetition systems alright I
did a fair amount of research on the
internet how people react how much time
they spend how useful to find it
many people swear by spaced repetition
systems in fact there was a comment here
on my channel from someone whose name I
can't remember explaining the scientific
basis for this program yeah let's begin
by what is a space repetition system
there are algorithms based on how
frequently we need to review thick
review things in order to remember them
and this the sort of freak frequency or
the space between you know the first
time we learn something then we need to
see it fairly quickly again and then we
can wait a little while before we see it
in other words based on the tendency of
the brain to forget things how you know
this based repetition system will
program it so that these things that
we're trying to learn will reappear at
the sort of optimum time for our
retention so these are used for example
by people studying history or science or
other things like that and so they will
create essentially flashcards with the
bits of information that they want to
retain and either and write them out
longhand and
for they have physical flashcards or
increasingly these things are done
electronically and of course it is an
advantage because we know from from the
research that Robert Bjork and others
have done that rereading the same
material over and over again is a bit
self-defeating every time we reread the
same thing this attempt that blocked
learning we're in fact retaining less
and less or that we're increasing our
ability to retain things less and less
whereas if you can select out things
that are important that you really want
to retain and then review them on this
spaced repetition basis the chances are
that you will retain those things better
Plus you are reviewing some of the same
material from a different angle
rather than in the sort of main body of
whatever text you're trying to learn but
when it comes to language learning I
think the situation is a little
different
first of all reviewing flashcards can
become quite time-consuming because you
know if you're learning 10 20 30 50 100
new words a day and you have to review
them 7 10 times pretty soon this builds
up trim to a tremendous number of words
that have to be reviewed and just a
little googling told me that people
spend anywhere from 30 minutes to 2-3
hours a day just reviewing their decks
of flashcards so that may in fact be an
effective way of learning but it means
that you're taking time away from your
other learning activities and remember I
still believe that the fundamental keys
the language learning are your attitude
whether you're enjoying it or not like
what you're doing second of all time you
spend with the language and third of all
developing the ability to notice now
certainly reviewing things in flashcards
flashcards does increase your ability to
notice in my opinion so I depart a bit
from crash and in that regard however
and so if you have eight hours a day to
spend studying
you spend two hours on flashcards and
two hours reading and two hours
listening and two hours speaking that's
gonna be very very good however if you
have an hour an hour and a half a day
which is the case for me and for many
people then like personally I don't want
to spend all that time on flashcards so
I think if we're gonna use spaced
repetition systems we have to become a
little bit more selective and so I think
some selective use of this kind of
technique is good in my own case when I
finish a lesson at Linc I'd like to
review the new words and phrases using
our what we call activities but here
again unlike simple flashcards I think
it's an advantage when you have a
variety of ways of reviewing them so in
our activities after a lesson you will
get this sort of random exposure to
flashcards to close test which is fill
in the blanks to multiple-choice which
is very easy to dictation which is more
difficult and to a reverse flash card we
have to translate from your own language
into the language that you're learning
so and you can then if you don't want to
do the more difficult tasks you can just
do the more simple ones you can adjust
that in your settings so I think
providing some variety is good and then
doing them immediately after you've been
exposed to them I think is very useful
however if I had to them regularly
review all of those new words seven
times
pretty soon again I end up with this
situation of having to spend two three
hours a day just going through my
flashcards and that kind of builds up
that burden so in order and this there
was a person on the different things
that I checked on Google who emphasized
that it is important to review things
that are important or you know really
difficult to learn so that you're very
selective in what you choose to put into
your flashcard system so again in my own
case at Linc I save words and phrases
but mostly I review
mostly phrases and possibly words but I
review those things that I have tagged
so if something is very important I
tagged it as key K ey this is a key word
or a key phrase so that I can just go
and review those I can review them as a
list which is often faster or I can
review them in this sort of activity
format that we have when I can control
how many different forms of activity
that I want to review also I can focus
on phrases because phrases embody
grammatical points which I have trouble
with so you know as I mentioned earlier
in Greek I might have the tag something
as our is store and perfect or in
Ukranian I'll tag something as
imperfective or perfective verbs and if
I'm not sure I'll look it up just to
make sure or I'll tag it for different
cases or if I was particularly anxious
to focus on the certain type of
vocabulary medical terms or for example
expressions related to the time then I
would tag for that and then I end up
reviewing those things that I consider
to be important or perhaps difficult
like some of the grammatical terms so I
can be selective in what I review and
and this gives me the opportunity then
to review some of these words and
grammatical structures first of all in a
concentrated way of things that are
important and and useful but also a
different approach to the same material
because to a large extent obviously most
of the words we're gonna see very often
or hear very often in our usual input
activity so we don't need to do those in
flashcards but to see some of those
words and phrases in isolation it's a
different perspective it helps us notice
when we next come across them in our
listening and reading so in all of that
then what I would say is that I think
it's important not to become a slave it
depends as I say if you have eight hours
a day six hours a day then spaced
repetition can be a very important part
of your learning don't forget that
learning words and phrases is different
from learning facts in the text if you
reread a history test every time you
reread you're sort of learning less and
less when you are committed to doing a
lot of interesting reading in a language
you are in fact exposing yourself to the
language naturally learning about
different things but it's not like as if
you're trying to remember everything
that was in that text so it's quite a
different situation exposing yourself to
language as opposed to trying to nail
down say history text so if you only
have an hour or an hour half a day
language learning I would still be very
selective in you know to the extent to
which you use SRS systems another
advantage of the way I approach using
flashcards or other activities is that
when I create a tagged list at Linc and
I'm gonna try once I get this movavi
software to work I start to figure out
how it worked properly I would show you
how I do this but I can then record this
list so if I have 25 items that are
instrumental case in ukranian I can
record for myself first the English then
the Ukrainian the Act
first of all of tagging it helped me
notice the act of reviewing it helped me
notice the act of recording it helped me
notice and that now I have something
that I can take with me and becomes
portable because in my own case 2/3 3/4
of my learning is listening so I don't
want to spend 2 or 3 hours a day in
front of a computer I want something
that I can listen to in the car while
doing dishes and so forth and these
recordings of my own tagged list is
another way of bringing these bits and
pieces details things that help me
notice making them portable so that I'm
able to get in the hour or hour and a
half a day that I want to spend learning
languages so a little bit of a long rant
I know it's a bit of a controversial
subject but that's how I see the role of
spaced repetition systems thank you for
this thing and if you and
enjoy these podcasts please subscribe
bye for now
[Music]